Summon the suit some in the suit what are you
saying the suit the suit and keep this safe
so be it
stephen what are you are you like living inside
of me it's a little more complicated than that
marc you look different
we protect the vulnerable and deliver justice
this is the best worst day of my life
Welcome back everyone we have a brand new moon
knight trailer to break down there's a whole bunch
of new scenes and new footage and a ton of easter
eggs if you're new to the channel i will be doing
videos for all the episodes when it starts next
week so be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a new round of the disney plus
giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite moment from the
trailer on the video this is actually the first
trailer where we've seen where steven grant has
tried to force a transformation into moon knight
by layla she's his friend who seems like she's an
archaeologist too because you see them in a lot of
the flashbacks too traveling through the desert
laila his friend trying to get him to summon the
suit so to speak while he's stephen grant all
while ethan hawk dr arthur harrow's character
seems like he's opening a portal between our
world in the pocket dimension where the gods are
trapped in summoning what seems like minions of
seth that's what it seems like these dogs are he
seems like he's fighting them later in the trailer
too in egyptian mythology seth was just one of the
other many gods as part of that egyptian pantheon
seth was the god of deserts storms disorder
violence it looks like ethan hawk's character
arthur hero commands some power using the other
ancient egyptian totems now the walking cane he's
using has a crocodile on it and the tattoo that
he has that shifts actually has the scales on it
those represent two different egyptian gods but it
also seems like he's trying to get that scare of
totem that steven grant is holding or marc spector
however you want to think about him it's the same
person technically but he's in steven grant form
when he's running with the totem we see arthur
harrell with a surprise look on his face using
the totem in another trailer so presumably he
gets a hold of it at some point and uses it to
gain access to whatever this pantheon is it seems
like it's some sort of device that activates a
portal between dimensions if you look at the other
featurette that they dropped a couple days ago too
it seems like there's some flashbacks where marc
spector and layla go searching in the desert and
find this place and gain entrance maybe they find
the scarab that also might be the location where
konchu's monument is where he becomes moonaight
for the first time but it seems like layla doesn't
find out that he's moon knight till they get back
to england or wherever they go back to that's
pretty much how it went down in the comics too
like he becomes moon knight and then he develops
his alternate personas and eventually his love
interest marlene learns his secret identity layla
seems like she's an upgraded version of marlene
combined with a couple different characters
like in the trailer you see layla taking out some
of these guards marlene wasn't this badass in the
comics this is also the first trailer we've
got where moon knight himself speaks out loud
now when he's in full moon knight costume or the
full suit costume he's moon knight but he's also
speaking as marc spector marc spector is meant
to be the avatar of konchu it's just that he can
also be regular marc spector walking around on the
street and playing clothes acting like a mercenary
the only alternate persona that we've seen so
far is stephen grant and it seems like a persona
that he slips into as a result of his death and
resurrection or was one of his aliases when he was
a mercenary before he became moon knight in the
trauma of becoming moon knight just put him down
so hard that when he woke up he woke up thinking
that he was fully stephen grant and not knowing
anything about moon knight or marc spector he did
laugh when he was talking about the accent for
steven grant because people were like what's the
deal with the accent man he said they explained
that during episode one like fully in context he
believes the accent the backstory is authentic but
then learns obviously that that is not the case
like oh you're the fake one i'm the real one marc
spectre is the real person that's the beauty of
moon knight in one of the later comics he actually
begins to question whether or not moon knight was
real or marc spector was real to begin with like
did moon knight create marc spector or did marc
spector create moon knight and it's all this grand
trick that khonshu was playing on him to help
him reconcile all of his different personalities
that's the beauty of khonshu is that he's not a
good god he's not an evil god either he's kind
of in this gray area he's all about executing
his will and marc spector just has a fragile
enough mind that he can work through him they are
taking a slightly different approach than they
took in the comics though mostly by simplifying
the alternate personalities i think there might
be a couple at the end of the series but
i think for now we're just gonna see two
marc spectre who is also moon knight and mr
knight if you want to think about him that way
technically one personality and steven grant in
the mcu steven grant being the shop owner selling
trinkets from ancient egypt inside this british
museum it even seems like he goes back to where
he believes he's from in england with that weird
accent and starts living stephen grant's life
that he originally created as a cover for marc
spector but thinking that it's a hundred percent
real until he starts seeing weird things konchu
starts appearing to him in his mind and eventually
marc spector speaks to him inside his head look
stephen you weren't supposed to see all this
the difference between this and something like
fight club is that in fight club they treated
the tyler durden persona like it was completely
separate person for most of the movie but in
moonet it seems like you learned pretty quickly
in episode one that marc specter and stephen grant
are the same person if you follow the comics
i like to think that moon knight has a happier
ending than fight club does anyway the difference
with fight club is that he reconciles both of his
identities like oh i've been the same person this
whole time and he defaults to his main persona but
in the moonlight comics the difference is that he
recognizes that he actually needs the alternate
personas and he finds a way to live with them and
use them to his benefit so he just continues on
with the multiple personalities i'm sure all the
other avengers are going to love that not knowing
who they're talking to on any given day when he
discovers marc spector's passports his weapons
and his locker it looks like he's in the rows
of storage areas that he's running down probably
because khonshu came to appear to him again we
haven't heard him speak out loud yet in any of
the trailers but kanju was portrayed by f murray
abraham you all remember him from somewhere he's
so iconic he's done so many movie and tv roles
cw i need you to draft an apology immediately
of course now are we apologizing to the nazis or
on their behalf we see his friend leila learn that
he's turned into moon knight she seems fairly
impressed by it she probably isn't conscious or
right there when he takes place for the first
time when he makes the bargain with konchu but
she might be an archaeologist or based on the
marlene love interest like i said before she was
a daughter of an archaeologist that he essentially
died protecting the night that he became moon
knight this is a state where he transforms into
moon knight taking out all these guards might
belong to arthur harrow in some totally different
scene you see him using his cloak to protect layla
from gunfire like you learned what some of his
abilities are for the most part he has enhanced
strength durability intellect his cloak provides
him a measure of protection from projectiles and
he can also take the crescent darts out of his
chest here too like you see him reach into his
chest and pull them out the crescent darts are
kind of like his version of batarangs you notice
when he's mr knight with a white suit and tie
he doesn't have any of those abilities though
he does have a walking stick that he can beat
people with that's sort of like his world's
greatest detective persona he's still in marc
spector moon knight persona when he's like that
it's just that that's the persona he uses when
he's liaising with the police or other authorities
if a bunch of criminals showed up and started
to beat on him then he would switch back to
regular moon knight form in the regular costume
then you see him in the bathroom of that scene of
him being the hell out of what we can now tell
are the seth dogs making me think that we will
see werewolf by night at the end of the series
instead of earlier in the series and he says we
protect the vulnerable we deliver justice but is
that conscious speaking or is that marc spector
speaking as moon knight one of the big things with
moon knight is who is really in control at any
given time is marc spector in control of himself
or is khonshu really in control of marc spector
because sometimes it will be konchu acting
through marc spector to execute as well
making marc spector only think that it's his
will like was this my idea or was this kanju's
idea he's not meant to be a nice god he targeted
marc spector just because he saw an opportunity
when he lay dying at the feet of his monument in
the desert he and the other gods that are part of
his pantheon this egyptian pantheon are trapped in
this alternate dimension they can only act in the
main mcu dimension through avatars so he doesn't
necessarily need a good person to be his avatar
he just needs someone with a weak enough mind that
he can control and will do his bidding the thing
he's not counting on is all the nice people around
marc spectre that help him be a good person like
in spite of all this marc specter tries to use his
powers to be a superhero this layla friend is a
good example the other avengers that he's going
to be crossing over with are great example like
blade kit harington's black knight werewolf by
night and like i said because it's the seth dog
in the bathroom now i'm thinking werewolf by night
is going to be a tag scene at the end or some post
credit scene or something right at the end of
the series where they tease the existence of
other supernatural creatures and i think that
they'll just cover werewolf by night's backstory
during his halloween special later this year
according to recent reports mahershala ali's
blade character is supposed to come back on screen
this time during that like for real on screen not
just a voice off-screen like in the eternal's
post-credits scene but big reminder moon knight
episode 1 starts next wednesday my full video
will post right after it airs just like all the
other marvel disney plus series that i've done
videos for if you have any special requests or
big questions about moon knight or konchi or the
gods or anything just leave them in the comments
and i'll add them to my bonus videos everyone
click here for my new doctor strange 2 trailer
breakdown and things you missed and click here
for my other moon knight bonus videos and trailers
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!